There's a question asked on the YouTube
by K edits. Assalamu alaykum. Walaykum.
Dr. Zakir Karan here a Muslim revert. My
question is are true six considered idol
worshippers? Can a Muslim man marry a
sick girl if they are considered idol or
fire worshippers? If you have heard my
talks on sikism, sikism actually is
against idol worship. They're againstar
that almighty god taking
sik a true sik who follow the scriptures
believe there's one god and they believe
that almighty god has got no image. He's
all powerful. The concept of God in
Sikism is close to the concept of God in
Islam. But it is the question is not
that a Muslim cannot only marry an idol
worshipper. A Muslim man or woman cannot
marry a non-Muslim man or woman. The
Quran says in surah bakar chapter 2
verse number 221, let not a believing
woman marry an unbelieving man or a idol
worshipper until he believes a slave man
who is a Muslim is far superior to a
non-Muslim even if he allows you. He may
be the most handsome man in the world.
He may be the richest man in the world.
He may be the king of the world. But a
believing man who's a bondsman, who's a
slave man, Allah says, is better than
unbelieving man. And even if he allows
you, he may be most handsome, he may be
most richest. And the verse continues
that do not marry unbelieving woman or a
mushria. So the two things idol
worshipper or unbeliever means those who
don't believe in Islam. Do not marry
unbelieving woman or a mushria until
they believe. A believing woman, a
Muslim, even if she's the born woman,
she's much better than unbelieving
woman. Even if she allows you, she may
be a beauty queen. She may be the
richest woman in the world. She may be a
queen of the richest country in the
world. But if she's unbeliever, a Muslim
woman who's a slave woman is far
superior than an unbeliever woman even
if she allows you. So based on this
verse of the Quran, you cannot marry a
non-Muslim. So the sick, even if it's
the true sick following who may not be
doing idol worship, can you marry? No.
You have to believe in the last time and
final messenger prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him. To marry the person should
be a Muslim. It's compulsory should be a
Muslim and the prophet said that when
you marry when you look for a life
partner you look for four things one is
beauty wealth nobility and virtue
religion that is deemed and the most
important from amongst all is virtue it
is seen so unless the non-Muslim accepts
Islam you cannot marry a non-Muslim hope
that answers the